several deaths confirmed after a  possible explosion at an ariana grande  concert police in Manchester England  have confirmed a number of fatalities  and injured victims following Ariana's  concert Monday night at Manchester Arena  the singers wrap a shirt et she's okay  and added they are further investigating  what happened here's video inside the  arena fans visibly shaken panicking as  they rush to exit one concert goer  tweeted everyone screamed and ran out  I've never been so scared in my life  ariana took to Twitter just hours after  the incident she lamented quote broken  from the bottom of my heart I am so so  sorry  I don't have words several stars also  express their heartfelt condolences  Taylor Swift  Demi Lovato Katy Perry Nicki Minaj Bruno  Mars and more shared messages on Twitter  praying for the victims and offering  their deepest sympathy  you